Alors, pour parler de cette
histoire, Guy Saint-Jacques,
Chine est avec nous. Monsieur
Saint-onsoir.
- Bonsoir, Monsieur Roy.
- Malheureusemenmière fois que ,
que des gens très connus en
Chine, quand ils critiquent
ouvertement le régime, où là,
encore pire, elle accuse
un personnage important de
l'avoi
Est-ce que c'est ce qu'il fautce
analyse à ce moment-ci? moi, je,
que c'est le régime qui essaie
de la faire taire par tous les
moyens, et peut-être pour deux
raisons. D'abordues. Et ce que
les Chinois craignent sûrement,
c'est que si elle parle, c'est
s'élargisse. Parce que je ne
serais pas surpris qu'il y ad'an
dont les athlètes chinois sont
élevés et préparés pour les
compétitions international
Et d'autre part, c'est une
année importante pour le parti
communiste chinois. Monsieur Xi
Jinpin
entériner un troisième mandat
lors de son congrès qui va avoir
Il faut qu'il donne l'image d'un
qui est pur, où les
dirigeants sont sans repro cette
histoire-là d'être... qu'on
fasse enquête, ça risquerait de
ternir l'image d
je pense qu'il pensait qu'enémea
calmerait le jeu et que les gens
d'autres cas, sachant la façondt
élevés et préparés pour les
compétitions internationales.
importante pour le parti
communiste chinois. Monsieur
Xi Jinping espèe parti
va entériner un troisième mandat
lors de son congrès qui va avoir
lieu l'an prochain en octobre.ùs
dirigeants sont sans reproche.
Et donc, de permettre àettre àee
histoire-là d'être... qu'on
fasse enquête, ça risquerait
de ternir l'image du parti.qu'e,
ça calmerait le jeu et que les
asseraient à autre chose.
Mais là, ça prend de l'ampleur,
et je pense que la machine
de pro
- Parce que c'es fil
blanc, son texte qu'elle a
publié, en disant : "Non, mais
finalement, je ne me
repose." C'est cousu de fil
blanc. Personne à ça.
Mais là, les Chinois sont
devant, quand même, une fronde
importante. La Wvous."
Comme vous dites, les Olympiques
qui arrivent. Qu'ils'ils'ils'ils
peuvent faire? Ils vont...
- Oui,de de fairde de fairde dee
des menaces. Et dans ce cas-ci,
probabils étaienils étaienils ét
certains que la WTA dirait :
"Bon, écoutez, on a tellement
d'enjeux économi
de dollars, qu'on voit passer
l'éponge là-ds,
M. Simon, le président
de l'association, persiste.
Et là, avec t
des vagues.
Et... je ne pen les
Chinois permettent une enquête.
Mais à tout le moins, ils vont
probablement orgpour
montrer qu'elle est bien, mais
en espérant que as
aller plus loin. Mais je pense
que là, c'est le moment
opportun, et je
étrangers, de s'intéresser à la
question et de ds
explications. Parce que sinon,
si on joue le jeine et
qu'on ne réagit pas, ça
l'encourage à continuer avec ce
genre
- Et cet homme qu'elle accuse,
bien, qu'elle accusait parce
qu'elle est revenue, mais
qu'elle accuse, Monsieur Gaoli,
était très puissant. Est-ce que
la Chine ne pourrait pas le
lâs un
procès", non?
- Bien, ils pourraient faire ça,
ça risquerait de soulever un
débat. Est-ce qu'il y a d'
cas comme ça? Et puis... où
des gens puissent se permettent
d'utiliser leur position p
force et avoir un comportement
tout à fait répréhensi
puis, je pense que c'est de ça
dont probablement le leadership
chinois est trè
de cacher l'affaire et de taire
toute l'histoirepensepensepensee
qu'à nouveau, il y a une
occasion de poursuivre
la question et d
- Et dites-moi, Guy Saint-
Jacqueand
patron Jack Ma d'Alibaba, très
riche, qui était, on disait,
l'hommes ennuis,es ennuis,es en,
lui aussi a disparu, entre
guille, c'est vraiment
une arme que le régime,
encore en 2021, emploie.
us en plus.
Parce qu'en fait, si on regarder
un message très puissant àoit ds
de technologie ou des compagnies
dans le domaine de l'éducation,s
les politiques du parti, vous
allez ussi
en leur disant, en amenant cette
notion de prospérité commune, er
à redistribuer la richesse
que vous avez accumulée."
Ils étaient aussi très inquiets
de l'influence des vedette
cinéma, des grands influenceurs.
Là aussi, ils en ont arrêté n'ar
impôt. Et tout ça, c'est pourr e
parce que le régime a
l'impression, pa
que les jeunes Chinois sont
en train de décrochers veulent
raffermir l'idéologie.
,
M. Biden qui jongle avec un
pas
général des Jeux de Pékin, mais
diplomatique, de ne pas envoyer
croyez qu'on
s'en va vers là?
Et puis, en
fait, ce qu'on aurait dû faire
il y a un an et demi, c'estats r
qu'il y a une enquête sur lasità
collaborer sur la vraie originee
COVID 19.
veut pas pénaliser les athlètes,
mais il faut env
qu'on ne va pas tolérer des
une entente
entre les pays occidentaux pour
dire qu'aucun pa
Jeux... aux cérémonies
d'ouverture. Je pense que là,
Xi Jinping commencerait à
comprendre qu'on
- On va s'en parler de ça, c'est
en février. On le rappelle, Guy
ambassadeur en Chine, du Canada
en Chie nouse nouse nouse nouses
avoir parlé.
- Merc